[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday May
23rd and this song is for the Yeti a
[Music]
year ago today my brother convinced a
girl to say I do and that girl was you
Pepa sir I've got to warn you
what you swore to you'll see
what I mean
nothing in the world could ever stop
John Green from achieving as one
unmatchable dream I don't think that he
would even stop at 19 he wants to entire
many at your soccer teams from EU
from your womb
eleven on each side the co-ed teams
would be just fine as
[Music]
if you don't take long
taina baby please
the mournful baby feet so cute
and then little Ambrose oops what I'm
glad you think the true the luckiest
girl in Indianapolis in all of the world
but I wouldn't think you'd be too keen
on birthing a miniature soccer team for
him
all for him
might seem inhumane it might sound like
a lot of pain unless you opt
to adopt
but John would probably just call me a
cynic I think he's already called
fertility clinics he's serious about
this
22 it is probably more than
but nothing in the world's gonna stop
John Green from see is many inter sundar
team I play all day to warn you
what you've sworn to John
is a big making machine
[Music]
Oh
Sara John I hope you're having a
marvelous time in the Netherlands watch
out for the babies do you never know
where they're gonna come from they could
come from the Netherlands I don't know
we could like more about that later if
you want to but I'm gonna go I'll see
you tomorrow
Oh aah Oh nerdfighters
for users of mac os/x nerdfighter
timothy Resendez has created the world
suck widget which will keep you informed
of world suck levels via your OSX
dashboard you can download it at
brotherhood to calm and if you're
already a brotherhood to calm you can
download it right there